[Captions by Y Translator]
In today's video,
we've got a fun build idea.
We're going to see
if we can build our very own
customized TKOR branding iron.
[Music]
Guys, we just got a welder,
a MIG welder.
I love welding,
and this is going
to be a lot of fun.
And as a first project,
we are going to make
a branding iron.
So I've got a steel bar.
I've got some
steel square tubing,
got a little bit
of all thread,
some wood, nuts.
Goal is to be able
to have a little metal logo
that we can heat up in a fire,
and then brand onto wood,
or maybe a steak,
or whatever else we
feel really needs
our logo burned right into it.
Not people.
Probably not cows either.
I don't think we have
any cows to brand.
It's a pretty basic idea.
We're going to cut
and shape the TKOR logo
out of some mild steel.
Use a welder to attach them
together, and add a handle,
giving us a branding iron
that we can use
on all sorts of stuff.
Now, I've gone ahead
and printed off the TKOR logo,
and what I'm going
to be doing is attaching
that to our metal bar here,
and I'm actually going
to take all four letters
and cut them up,
and then we're welding stuff,
we'll put them back together.
That's just going to make
it a lot easier to get some
of the angles and stuff,
the down in the little
nooks and crannies.
So we're going to separate all
the letters, glue them down
to this piece of steel,
and we're going to start
cutting them out.
[Music]
Wood glue actually
does a fantastic job
attaching paper to metal.
[Music]
Well, there's a few ways
you can cut this out.
I'm going to start
with a hacksaw.
We'll see if I decide
to keep using the hacksaw,
or if I just move on
to using an electric grinder.
[Music]
Who was it that said something
about a metal grinder?
Heck, I had a good idea.
[Music]
Kind of got
the rough form cut out.
Now, we got to start doing
a little bit finer details.
Of course, we won't necessarily
do everything with a grinder,
we'll get some files,
maybe a rotary grinder as well.
We've got options.
[Music]
I've got the four letter pieces
cut out for our TKOR symbol,
and now I need to
start welding together.
The T and K should be connected.
The O and R should be connected.
And so we want to do that
before we put all the pieces
together with the backer rod,
and then attach the handle.
So we're just going
to be welding--
We're actually going
to do it on the front.
That is going to leave
a little bit of buildup.
We're going to have to grind
that down afterward,
but it should leave a nice
smooth connection
between the pieces when I'm done.
A great connection?
Hopefully, it's
enough connection.
[Music]
Nice.
That work great.
There we go.
We've got a weld right
across the seam.
Hopefully, it's a good clean
weld all the way through,
and when I sand that down,
it will just be nice
and smooth with no bubbles
or anything inside.
[Music]
So for those of you
who may not know,
this right here,
that's a magnet.
This is great for holding all
of your pieces in place,
and it's got a nice
90 degree angle on it,
gives you some
measures and stuff.
This right here is what allows
it to complete a circle,
and I'm pushing this button.
It's sending electricity
through both of these,
and it welds because it's trying
to complete the circuit.
So this has to be in contact
with what you're welding
ahead of time,
and as it feeds this wire out,
the wire comes
in contact with it.
It makes an arc and
that's what welds.
All right.
Let's do a little bit clean
up on these two.
Are they cool enough to touch?
They're not super burning hot,
but they're too hot.
[Music]
Well guys...
Brands work in reverse.
So this one looks
really good on camera.
But if I brand
anything with it,
it would read TKOR backwards.
So I'm going to try and cut
off these weld marks.
Weld this piece
to the other side,
and then clean it up again.
All right, we've
got some charcoal,
what we're going to do is
we're gonna put our brand down
in the charcoal,
get it nice and hot,
add a little bit
of extra air to just
really get that thing going.
Hopefully, we can get
this really nice and hot,
and then start
burning some stuff.
[Music]
All right, now
it's not glowing red.
Part of this
because it's daytime out here.
But I'm guessing we have plenty
of heat to get a good brand.
[Music]
Bam, that is beautiful.
It brands wood really well,
but there's another thing
we want to try.
Now, we're not going
to brand a live cow
because we don't have
one of those,
and we don't own it,
and have no reason to brand it,
but we do have
a steak from a cow.
We're going to see
what happens if we try
and brand that steak.
[Music]
Right as I braided
that, there's a cow.
I don't know like
a few properties over.
I swear it just...
It knew.
[Music]
Yeah, that's good
branded right there.
[Music]
Taste branded.
It actually does,
there's like an extra little bit
of charred flavor to it.
It's quite good.
[Music]
Guys, you've probably noticed
that since we introduced
Calli in our Captain
America shield video,
every new video
has had secret codes,
graphic glitches,
and other secret elements
hidden into it.
Keep track of what you see,
and the timestamp
of when you see it.
We've got some big
prizes to give away,
and finding the codes
might make you our next winner.